The Joe Rogan experience.
What was your experience like the whole SNL debacle thing? What was that like?
Uh, it was very, very crazy. I don't know. It's tough to,
there's not many people that have, you can even talk to about it, you know?
Cause it, it you up a little, like it makes you like, uh,
not trust people and for a while. Like in what way? I don't know.
I don't know how to explain it. It's but back to the main,
the experience of it was like, you just, uh, it was kind of surreal.
Cuz I went from,
I was one of the first people to get like canceled or however you wanna say it
consequences. However, yeah.
However you wanna say it doesn't matter what we call it is what it's. Right.
But uh, I was one of the first people to go from.
I was doing, I was poor. I was not famous at all. I was poor.
And then I got canceled immediately. Like that was my like right.
It was a very different didn't experience.
Didn't get famous and then get most people that get canceled or yeah,
you got canceled on the way I got canceled immediately. Yeah. They,
they literally were like, how about this guy? And everyone was like, no.
So you got cast on SNL? Yes. And then what happened? Um,
so I found out I was getting on SNL the day before they announced it.
So I got a call. They're like, Hey,
we wanna put you on the cast the whole time I was we'll start from the top.
<laugh> my, my agents and all those people, they were like,
you're do you want to, or do you wanna write,
do you wanna send a packet in for SNL? And I was like, no,
I'm not gonna be a writer. I'm never gonna, I won't work on that show.
And then I guess they saw me a JFL and comedy central thing. And they were like,
we like him. We want him to audition. He can come straight into audition.
So I went straight to the main stage for the audition and the whole time leading
up to it, I was like, I'm never, I'm never gonna get this. I, I don't care.
I wanna do standup. I kind of hated SNL at that point.
<laugh> cuz every ti every sketch was like, you know, you know what it is. Yeah.
And then I was like, I'll never fit in there. And then when we,
when you go to audition, it's just,
you just wait your turn in a green room and they keep you there extra long for
like two or three hours to like make you nervous really. But I knew I,
I was certain, I was never gonna get it. And I really wasn't nervous.
I was in there dip and hanging out <laugh> and then they were like, all right,
it's your turn to, but that's when the nerves hit,
like you walk in and you see the main stage cuz that's what you audition on is
like the stage. Wow. And it's a totally empty studio.
The whole room's empty except for a table of like writers and producers and
Lauren Michaels. And then you go on and they're like three, two,
go do five minutes. Wow. In front of just a camera. Right.
And are you doing stand up? I did stand up. Wow. I did five minutes of standup.
That's all. And then, uh,
I ran into Michael Che that night and I was like, I was so nervous.
Like I was so nervous when I was auditioning that I had to like,
hold the mic against my chin. Cuz my hand was shake. It was crazy.
There's no one in the room.
You just have to do standup for five minutes to no one. That's so weird.
It was so, and,
and you're not supposed to look at or acknowledge the table of writers and
producers or.
Whatever, why they have rules.
They have rule, they have rules that your agents tell you.
Oh they never told you any rules. So your.
Agent says, do not look at the writers.
Yeah. They're like, don't even acknowledge them. Pretend the room's full,
just go. And everybody was like, they're never gonna laugh the table, Lauren,
all them, they're not gonna laugh. First thing I said,
they all started laughing and I was like,
I was supposed to not acknowledge 'em but you know, I was doing stand ups.
Do you remember what you said? No,
I don't genuinely. You just, just did a bit. Yeah. I was just, yeah,
I was nervous. Uh, but as soon as they started laughing,
I was like <laugh> and then went back to, you know what I mean?
I was like looking at 'em. I, I could see they were laughing and you,
I was told the whole time, no one's gonna laugh. They were laughing.
And I was like, oh. I did pretty good. Ran into cha that night. I was like, ah,
I sucked. I was nervous. He was like, no, you were, I was good.
Then a couple days later you get a call back and you go into the office and you
meet everybody and you walk around and talk to everybody.
And the people I was with that were also doing that.
Then you go into Lauren Michael's office to meet him.
So the three people I was with, they all went in, slowly, met him,
left one guy didn't even get invited. They just sent him home, which is up.
They invited him to the callback and then were like, no, nevermind. Wow.
And then they kept me there for an extra like hour by myself.
And I was just sitting there like, oh, I got this. Like, I'm gonna be on it.
Like this is, I can't believe I got this. I wasn't even excited.
I was just like, this is wild. <laugh> this is nuts.
And then I go in and meet with Lauren and he's he's the man, he's a nice guy.
And he was like, oh, I'm gonna use you. But I don't know how.
And like all that.
And then time passes and I figured they were gonna ask me to be a writer.
Cuz that's usually how it goes. Yeah.
Usually you work on the show to ex experience what the show's like,
but I don't know. I didn't wanna be a writer.
By all accounts. That places a den of thieves. Everybody. Yeah.
A den of thieves. You, you hear Jim Brewer's account of the,
the climate in that place. Yeah. And it's horrific. Yeah.
They're all stealing from rider. They're stealing from performers.
If you're a writer and you submit packages, the,
the higher up writers will steal your according to brewer. Yeah.
If you submit a package, they own that package. Even if they don't hire you.
I know that. So if you have some great premises, they decide,
they're just gonna take your premises and not hire you. They,
they own all those bits. Yeah.
It's crazy. I mean, yeah. I don't, I don't, I don't,
I don't care about out writing. I didn't wanna be a writer. Right. Of course.
So I was like, if, even if they offered me the writing thing, I was like, I,
I don't want to take it. I think I would've at the time. But anyway, they,
they asked me to go straight to cast. So I was like, yeah,
I'll definitely do that. Lauren calls says, Hey,
we want to use you on the show. We're gonna announce it tomorrow. He was like,
do you have anything? Uh, you want us to check out?
Like they have people that vet you. Right. But they,
they're not used to people having podcasts. Right.
So they'd have to go through hundred.
Stories. They, they go through your Facebook, your Instagram, your Twitter. I,
I was just like, I'll just delete all that. I don't care. Delete it. All right.
But I was like, I also have a podcast. And they were like, yeah, what's that?
And I was like, I don't know. I say like gay and retard a lot.
<laugh> and they were like, they were like, oh, that's fine.
Don't worry about it. <laugh> so I was like, all right, we'll see. And uh,
so the day they announced it, it was, it was cool. It was very cool.
You hear from everybody you've ever grown up with they're all like, holy. What?
Just like, I can't believe you're on this. And then,
so that lasted for about like three hours before an article came out.
That was like, here's what this guy says. There's a clip of me saying something,
you know, unsavory stuff. Yeah.
But talking.
It was, it was the one podcast we ever filmed.
That's the one they used. Wow. And it just happened. And it was funny too.
Cuz people were like, man, they really had to dig to find this. I was like,
yeah, it's probably like three minutes in <laugh>. It was like,
we had one podcast online and it was three minutes in. Well, uh.
It's what we were saying earlier.
That's what podcasts are and what comics do a lot. We talk.
It doesn't mean you really mean those things.
But the idea today is that talking is not real.
They want to take out of context,
phrases and sentences that you've used and put 'em in quotes and make you look
like a monster.
Yeah. Yeah. For sure. It was only one.
Article that came out.
No, there's a, quite a few, so many articles. I was,
I think I was number one on Twitter for like three straight days. Wow.
Of just getting eviscerated. Did you read it all? Oh, I read all of it. Oh no.
Yeah. Everybody was like stop reading com. I still read comments.
I read every comment. Why? I don't know. Oh, it's it's up. And it's crazy too.
Cause I'll read like 90 good ones and then one bad one.
The one bad one will you up. Just depends which one it is. Right. You know,
I I'll get called like uh, you know, fat retard constantly. I'll be like, yeah,
whatever. I, I can walk through that. No problem. Right.
But then there'll be one that's like he's nerve like something,
something where they get you where they, they know you. Yeah.
Like he laughs at his own jokes on every podcast. It's like, oh.
Do I.
Right. Anyway.
So I get all that stuff comes out and it was funny.
This is funny.
I went into Lauren's Lauren Michael's office and he was talking and I was
convinced I was getting fired. Like I knew I was getting fired.
Cuz if they didn't get me on that, there's so much more, it's so much worse.
And uh, so he was talking to me and he was like, no, we think we can.
He's like, if we just get you to the first episode, like people will see,
you're not a piece of person. Right. Like just talk. And I was like,
whatever I'll do. If I just, if I get fired here, whatever,
I'll just go do Joe Rogan next week and I'll be fine.
Anyway. I thought that was funny. No, what? I was like, I,
I literally what you thought. I literally thought that. Oh, okay. Yeah.
I thought it'd be funny.
Well, it could have been funny. Yeah. Was booked up though. No.
It's fine. I,
it was just funny to truly that was a conversation I actually had really
in Lauren Michael's office in the middle of that, that's hilarious. I, it was,
I was in pure panic terror. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
But cuz I remember somebody contacted me like to have you on.
And I was like, I don't have any room.
Like for a long I could do like an emergency podcast, but I'm like, let,
let this dude ride this out. Yeah. And then we'll do one eventually.
Truly glad that that did not happen. Cause I would've come in emotional.
I would've come in like guns blames me. Isn't fair. And,
and I never felt that way. Like the whole time I was like, I.
Kind of get it when someone get it's really canceled. You need perspective.
Yeah. You need, you know what it's like, it's like,
you need that venom to work its way through your system. And then you develop a,
a certain amount of immunity to the actual moment. Yeah.
Absolutely. Yeah. Yeah. It was, it ended up being a good thing. So.
When Lauren pulls you in the office and says,
we just have to get you to the stage,
we just have to get you to an then what happens?
It just, it just kept, it just kept steam rolling. Like it never,
it didn't dissipate at all. Like it kept being like, no,
you guys need to fire 'em and I get.
It. And then because, well that's where the fun is. Yeah.
The fun in going after someone is not going after someone and then no
consequences that makes them sad. Yeah.
What's makes them be so they can get you fired. Yeah.
And that's yeah, they did. They did a good job. Yeah. Good job buddy. Yeah.
And it's fine. Look the whole time dude.
Here's why it's fine. Your sketches that you're doing, what is it? Gillion. KES.
Yeah. Those are the best comedy sketches that are on the internet right now.
Thank you. I'm not bullshiting.
The only thing that's at the same level is Kyle Dungan. Oh man. Kyle Dungan.
The that he's doing. God dude, because he's got a,
a massive advantage with that face swap.
Though. And he's so good at impressions.
He's amazing. His, have you seen the new thing that Dunigan is doing?
He's done a, the, the, the, what is it? The,
he does a fresh prince takeoff with Biden. What is.
It called? Yeah. Fresh prince of these. See? Yeah. Or something fresh.
Press. Something like that. Fresh press. Yeah dude. It's it's tear jerking.
His bill Moore. Oh my God. It's incredible.
New rule. Yeah. It just, oh.
My God. And it's,
there's something about it that it's almost got like a south park S quality to
it. Yeah, because it looks so fake, but it's obvious. It's like, it's like the,
these things like, look how bad these look,
look at the little tiny hand he holds up for bill Mar like the face swap thing
is amazing. It really is amazing because he's like,
look at the AOC cuz it looks so fake.
Like you would never believe that that's the real person. So it's comedic,
but it it's also the, the materials. Brilliant.
And you can get away with so much in someone else's voice when everybody knows
it's not really that person. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
It's really one of the most genius platforms ever created. Yeah.
And he's the master. Him and him. Kurt medir Kurt is they're incredible.
They're.
They're both. Yeah. Kurt. It's the best. Kurt's like one of my,
he's one of my favorite.
Comedians, but the you're doing is right up there with that. It's really funny,
man. It's really funny.
And it's like something you would never be able to do on SNL.
The stuff you guys are doing, how are you financing this stuff? Uh.
I financed half. Then we had a production company that finance half.
The Trump one was made the trumps speed dating <laugh>.
Yeah. It's John McKeever. He's KES. He's incredible writer.
He writes all these added. Some makes some he's.
They're really good, man. Yeah. They're really good.
I spazzed on the, that SNL.
Story. No, you didn't at all. How do you spell? It? Felt like it came out bad.
No, no, no. Look it's awkward story.
It is.
I it's always here's what's uncomfortable about it is I don't wanna sound like
it's weird for me to rail against cancel culture. Cause I was a,
a victim of it for lack of a better word. You know what I.
Mean? Why is it weird for you to rail again?
I don't know. I don't know. I just, it, it.
Makes me seems defensive. Yeah.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> yeah. I'd rather just be like, look,
if people bring up cancel culture, I'm just like.
Happens. Honestly, that happens.
I really believe it's better for you in the long run. I really do.
You're a brilliant comedian and I think your sketches are incredible.
And I think it's better that you not get attached to something that's ultimately
corrupting. And I don't wanna.
Be on the other side of it where it's like,
I'm a free speech guy. I'm a, it's like, dude,
I don't wanna be involved in any of this. I just wanna do comedy.
Catch new episodes. The Joe Rogan experience for free only on Spotify.
Watch back catalog J E videos on Spotify,
including clips easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on Spotify.
You can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can
download episodes to save on data cost. All for free.
Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the JRE on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify now to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan experience.